you welcome to this video dead sorry
therefore the somewhat strange start
ahead so the window with configuration
was somehow screwed up so I had to
restart the whole thing are we close to
Halloween someone going for the
Halloween gambit no so that's not very
exciting the Scotch four nights and but
anyway what can you do try to be a bit
more creative here what did our own you
do Bishop to b6 er rook e8 and Bishop to
d6 it's very likely not the best
possible setup but at least there is a
somewhat somewhat term yeah
unconventional so just taking andy sixx
or letting him take what it would be a
funny pawn structure but i don't think
it's any good so let's take
yeah that's probably equal about equal
the structure is a little bit worse but
White's pieces are not particularly
threatening their see threatening f5
much not really but going maybe Ruby
narrow p8 is probably yeah it's not so
bad let's do it Queenie 5 actually
attacks the night saw but he will
probably take anyway I wonder if G how
crazy g5 is in this position it's a bit
crazy but it's an interesting move
between f3 Queenie 5i hit yogi goes for
that tempo five anyway maybe or never ok
it's also threatening f41 now so yeah I
guess I have to do that taking on a
seven it's probably possible it's it's a
bit cheeky but yeah you can probably do
it rook b7 Quino Quino five is not
possible I'm sorry then Queen eight
seven rupees seven wins the knight on c3
I think unless there's some tactic with
e 527 group is 723 Quincy 35
I could just bought the Queen that's not
working at all so we cannot take b7 I
sorry you cannot take a seven okay just
back he wants to go to see form at the
end of all this not a bad idea so one
itm could be yeah maybe just do that
come on getting nervous their idea what
to also has them it also has nitin
Knight to f3 yeah I am definitely that I
did not think about it all my idea was
Bishop is six simple move yeah but he's
got night of three this I but this is
I'm playing this very loose him a very
loose way I doubt that I'm okay here
every doubt that it looks it looks kind
of shaky orders
that was my idea that i get there
foursquare i can trade that's a good
news that too good at that's good news
ham it's aged three possible to take hmm
don't see why not don't really see it so
it's crap
legend 2014 I've got a 50-percent score
against the sky
don't see him hmm sorry I didn't see a
particularly threatening move maybe
maybe even have 6 i'm stopping e5 i
might have had a five years it's a
kitchen clock hey how long is this going
to beep yeah I think I have to tie it
off
oh I didn't I was lucky if we should be
five anyway I have to get my loan a
night back into the action 96 maybe 494
I'm ship c4 no I'm not sure do I want to
take them it's not clear to me now let's
let's just do this get out of possible
Bishop c4 moves no 94 I was my idea okay
maybe just here so that i can take
capture on g 5y agency wants to go maybe
you can push him away from the air foul
and then go back here ty morning he that
was the neighbors so what happens he is
going back right it's difficult
difficult to make substantial progress
maybe i can go for this and 45 him
hmm Bishop takes for Knight f3 maybe
he's in a pin huh looks active at least
check okay it's a check that's not so
bad here a bloke that so go to adds a
good end game so going now up here it
should it should win somehow with age
three and so on no didn't want to
blunder this the c6 porn but you didn't
take it check check check check check
mate not that slow hmm Jim Jim I guess
it was mostly about him giving away the
83 porn for nothing but I didn't I think
my position looked somewhat somewhat
unsound them aged g5g five is home but
okay it's a somewhat boring position and
sometimes you have to take a little bit
of risk to get some imbalance going here
yeah and now this night h5 business I
don't know it's actually the computers
move funny i play mostly comp moose and
he gave away the porn
should be 65 66 is not very well liked
by the engine it wants to go Bishop e7
but what is the problem but should be
too oh yeah that was much better of
course mmm I didn't think about that
move yeah I cannot go back because of G
form oops and this means i have to go
there that's awful that's awful I should
have done that yeah that was much better
be should be true ok and now I think
everything is kind of in order again
even though it's not like an automatic
window so it looks pretty good we have
very decent winning chances there jack
just wondered I later i blundered the
the porn at one moment was it good fam
to change it I am still losing as Bishop
before yeah yeah ok I think that was it
was then a little bit better than our
thought I really had the feeling that
around this point right here that that
there might be something something
really good for what I couldn't really I
didn't see anything but all this feels a
little bit little bit little bit wrong
it seems that there's no no real
reputation ok well thanks for watching